the notion that we did not accept the
heroes act from the house
is not news and the notion that trying
to put the heroes act on the floor of
the senate
without the opportunity for debate or
amendment
is also not the right way to try to
build bipartisan legislation for a deal
i also find it incredible that this
administration's actions
sanctioning russia are considered to be
a pinprick
in comparison to whatever greater
sledgehammer is
is supposedly needed the katsa
legislation that i referenced
which was passed in the first year
following the election of president
trump
which president trump signed and
supported
was a massive increase in american
sanction authority against
russia and in north korea by the way
and has been utilized more by this
president than any sanctioned authority
that any other president has ever had
and the sanctioned regime that we are
putting in place today against russia
is designed to go aggressively
at election interference and the
argument that
nobody is doing anything is simply wrong
now i stand ready to work to build even
stronger sanction regimes that can
work without destroying our own economy
or work without destroying
our own industry in different sectors
which is part of the problem with a bill
that is being proposed without amendment
here today
but we need to recognize that the
accusations
that this administration and this senate
do not take election interference
seriously
when we pass the most significant
sweeping legislation
that has ever been passed in this
country to deal with it
and that there is no effort to try to
work on the covet relief package
is part of frankly the political attack
of the day
i'm sorry this is simply wrong
if we want to work together on either of
these two issues or other issues we
can on this floor but we can't do it
by these kinds of motions to adjourn and
unanimous consent requests to bring
bills to the floor
and pass them without amendment um
with is it's just not the way and my
colleague knows this is the kind of
thing that republicans and democrats do
they want
to bring attention to their legislation
but that's not the way you build a
bipartisan agreement that can actually
become law
thank you mr president brief in in
response um
this is a bipartisan bill it's a
bipartisan bill it's got bipartisan
co-sponsorship we've been working for
three years we've made changes
and the proof that everything we're
doing right now is not working
is the fact that we just had the dni say
we continue to have russian interference
and other
interference in our election that's why
we've got to do something
senator from texas mr president i've
enjoyed the colloquy here between
our colleagues on election interference
um i'm privileged to serve on the senate
select committee on intelligence
that's undertaken a three and a half
year long investigation of the election
interference that occurred
in 2016 and uh
i think the uh the five volume
report of the select committee on
intelligence bipartisan report is
indicative of the seriousness with which
we all
uh treat this subject
but i appreciate the senator from idaho
the chairman of the banking committee
for his comments for refreshing all of
our memories
about huge amounts of money that we
spent
in assistance to state election state
and local election authorities
as well as the good work being done done
by the department of
homeland security to help them secure
their networks against cyber attacks
and uh as well as other elements
of the united states government
including our intelligence community the
national security agency and others
this is important work but i agree with
him this is not
how we actually build bipartisan
consensus here
by coming and asking for unanimous
consent without going through the
appropriate procedures and
and frankly the hard work that it takes
to build consensus
but mr president on another matter today
the senate judiciary committee
advanced the nomination of judge amy
coney barrett to serve on the supreme
court
throughout her hearing last week judge
barrett
wowed america and certainly my
constituents in texas with her
impressive knowledge of the law
and her clear understanding about the
limited but important role that judges
play
in our republic she followed the
precedent
set down by ruth bader ginsburg
the so-called ginsburg rule and
refrained from answering questions on
how she would rule
in future cases or commenting on
contentious political issues
and i think she was correct to do so we
shouldn't embroil
judges in the political controversies
that we debate here
judges are not policymakers primarily
they're certainly not accountable to the
voters
they have lifetime tenure that's why
their responsibilities are
limited but important at the same time
nor by asking her her questions back in
2017
about her her religious beliefs whether
she is an
orthodox catholic state having to listen
to statements like well the dogma lives
loudly within you
because she's a woman of faith
suggesting that somehow she would
violate her
oath as a judge and impose her own views
instead of
the law from the role
from the bench well
judge barrett i think took all of us to
school a little bit
and reminded us very clearly that it's
the judge's job to impartially apply the
laws written
whether it's the constitution itself or
the laws that congress passes
she not only stated her commitment to
this most basic
principle but she also has a record
to back it up during her time on the
seventh circuit court of appeals
judge barrett has sided with her
colleagues 95 percent of the time
in more than 600 cases
it's no surprise the american bar
association which
the minority leader has called the gold
standard
gave judge barrett its highest rating
saying she's well qualified to serve
on the supreme court but we all knew
that
as i looked around the room during the
first day of questioning i noticed all
the binders that
people like i and my other colleagues
had notebooks piles of paper
books reference books on both the desks
of republican and democratic members of
the committee if my colleagues materials
preparing for this historic hearing were
anything like mine they included
previous decisions by judge barrett
academic writings
letters of support detailed background
information about her career
but i noted that as judge barrett was
answering our questions
she seemed to be doing so without even
glancing down at any notes
so i asked judge barrett i violated the
number one rule that you learn as a
lawyer not
to ask a question you don't know the
answer to but i did it anyway because i
had a hunch
and i asked her to hold up the notepad
sitting in front of her to show us what
materials
she had been using during the hearing
and it was a memorable moment she held
it up and smiled
and it was blank i think that spoke
volumes
about her competency her preparation
her intelligence all things that would
commend her
confirmation
well with each question she answered
judge barrett demonstrated her vast
knowledge of the law she made clear she
understood as i said the limited role
of judges and she showed compassion
and heart as she poured herself into her
work each and every day
numerous senators have noted that under
ordinary
circumstances a nominee like this would
get overwhelming
support but unfortunately these aren't
normal circumstances
our colleagues on the other side made
clear from the get-go that for them this
confirmation process
wasn't even about the nominee or her
qualifications
they attempted to hijack the hearing and
use it for
well it's a harsh word but it's true
fear-mongering last week's hearing was
like split screen tv on one half
republican senators asked the judge
about her judicial philosophy
prior rulings in a range of
constitutional doctrines
on the other half our democratic
colleagues delivered monologues about
obamacare
about a future case that she may
be called upon to participate in and
they attempted to convince the american
people that if she was confirmed she
would somehow
take away their health care
well that's at bottom an insult
to the judge somehow presumes that she
is
essentially auditioning for the job
based on a ruling in a future case that
would violate
every aspect of a judge's oath as judge
barrett noted judges don't make policy
pronouncements
they decide cases and she very carefully
just
described the case that's pending in
front of the supreme court
it's not about obamacare writ large
it's about a technical doctrine called
severability if one part of a statute's
deemed unconstitutional
and this one i believe is the individual
mandate because we zeroed out the
penalty
under uh the tax cuts and jobs act the
question is does the rest of the
legislation does the rest of obamacare
stand or does it all have to be struck
down
well she noted that there have been a
number of cases decided recently
by the current supreme court that seemed
to treat severability
with particular care and indeed
as a scholastic as an academic i think
and now that she and others noted that
it's not exactly
appropriate for judges to go out and
strike down statutes
except to the extent that they are
unconstitutional
well she said if they're not coming for
your health care then they'll
she'll serve corporate interests destroy
the environment somehow
chip away at our liberties well these
are nothing but baseless scare tactics
and stunts from our democratic
colleagues the latest one came this
morning
when they actually boycotted the
judiciary committee
vote on judge barrett they couldn't even
bob be bothered to show up and vote
against the nominee they claim is a
threat
to our democracy so you know what judge
barrett was confirmed unanimously
by the senators present today
instead in their chairs they had large
photographs much like we've seen at
sports arenas and ballparks
in the wake of the pandemic since we've
had to socially distance and you can't
have a large crowd at the ballpark so
they
people have these cutouts that's what it
looked like in the judiciary committee
today
and as i said because of their antics
because of this stunt senator graham
asked for unanimous consent to proceed
with the markup and of course there was
no objection
because any potential objector
had voluntarily absented themselves
but the truth of the matter is judge
barrett's qualifications speak
louder than the unsubstantiated claims
made by
her opposition she graduated at the top
of her class
from notre dame law school she held two
prestigious clerkships including
on the supreme court and she's litigated
in the trenches
before transitioning into academia where
she wrote and taught
constitutional constitutional law
about our federal courts and statutory
interpretation
and as i said for the last three years
she's put
all that great experience and training
to work on the seventh circuit
this is an exceptional judge with a
clear clear record of faithfully and
impartially
applying the law and she will bring
additional value to the united states
supreme court
the thing i one of the things i thought
was so remarkable is judge barrett is
also an incredible role model
and i think should be in her elevation
to the highest court in the land should
be an encouragement
to young women who aspire to
professional success
and as a great role model on how to
balance
what we all try to figure out how to
balance which is your professional and
your personal life
well she and her husband do a marvelous
job with their seven
children both being full-time
professionals
if confirmed she'd be the first mother
of school-aged children to serve as a
justice and only the fifth woman to
serve on the high court
she would also be the first justice on
the court
current court with a degree from a law
school other than yale
and harvard and bring much needed
educational diversity to the bench
judge amy coney barrett will serve our
country well on the high court
and i have full faith in her ability to
faithfully and impartially apply the law
as written i want to thank chairman
graham
for leading a fair and respectful
hearing the ranking member senator
feinstein made that observation and
i thought that was very generous and
civil of her
i would note that many of the more
radical
folks on the left have attacked senator
feinstein for her civility
and they're just wrong and i think she
remains a good role model for all of us
we can have our disagreements without
being
rude or uncivil or disagreeable
and i think senator feinstein is a model
for that
so i'm proud to support judge barrett's
nomination
in the judiciary committee mr president
i look forward to voting for her next
week
here on the senate floor
the senator from connecticut thank you
mr president
mr president uh there are a lot of
inscriptions
famous words inspirational sayings that
are
detailed into and painted on to the
walls of the capitol
one of my favorites which i think also
happens to be one of the
shortest adorns a wall i believe on the
way into the house
chamber the saying is attributed to
alexander hamilton
and it reads
okay
[Music]
um